wir schauen auf ein foto der 10 jährigen
lucie sie sehen es hinter uns ein foto
dass deutschland bewegte naja sie sehen
ein mädchen völlig erschöpft von den
aufbauarbeiten nach der todesflug sie
legte auf dem schlamm sofa ihrer
großmutter und schläft es sind bewegende
aufnahmen aus dem august dieses jahres
die todesflug im juli dieses jahres hat
zahlreiche häuser zerstört
auch dass der 10 jährigen lucie im
august berichtet bild über das mädchen
aus swisttal das von den aufräumarbeiten
erschöpft auf ihrem schlamm sofa liegt
und eine nation ist bewegt
ihre familie wurde hart von der flut
getroffen seit monaten ist kein normales
leben ermöglicht ihre ferien hatte sie
sich eigentlich anders vorgestellt
nach dem hochwasser sind die
sommerferien ganz anders geworden ich
war damit beschäftigt schlamm zu
schippen
elektronisch schubkarren zu fahren in
einmal ketten zu stehlen und am schuften
bis zum gehtnichtmehr ich habe mir die
sommerferien so vorgestellt dass ich
eigentlich mit meinen freunden
irgendwelche sachen machen könnte
fahrradtour mit oma und opa zum beispiel
ins schwimmbad und alles oder mit meiner
besten freundin maren ganzen tag im pool
verbringen und zu sagen ihr
größter traum mit ihrer familie einen
ausflug in einen freizeitpark zu
unternehmen für 48 stunden mal alles
vergessen doch angesichts der
finanziellen herausforderungen nach der
flut ist es den eltern leider nicht
möglich los hier diesen traum zu
erfüllen aber vielleicht passiert ja
doch noch ein kleines weihnachtswunder
[Musik]
und jetzt sind sie bei uns lucy und auch
ihre mama sind uns zugeschaltet schönen
guten tag los hier schönen guten tag
frau kraus erste frage wie ihnen heute
es ist eigentlich im moment
ein bisschen kalt draußen aber wir haben
ja wieder anheizen
die dinge die man sich freut einen tag
vor weihnachten werden immerhin wieder
eine heizung nach all den strapazen die
sie zusammen durchgemacht haben
richtig ja
dieses bild frau kraus und lucy dass wir
hier im hintergrund auch bei uns noch
sehen können sich noch daran erinnern
wie ist das entstanden
das ist ein montag erst noch
unter dach
einschließlich immer weiter mit
großen radlader straße gefahren und
haben lassen geräumt aber lösen
versuchen wir uns einfach eingeschlafen
was ist denn seitdem seitdem dieses foto
entstanden ist alles in ihrem heimatort
im swiss teil passiert
die aufräumarbeiten die straßen sind
eigentlich wieder frei die häuser weiter
also im rohbau
haben immer noch keine haltung bringt
wir haben gestern neue fenster rein
gekommen aber man muss einfach auch
damit er drauf hat er estrich herein
kann das sind die ziele die wir jetzt
haben
und was sind die träume die sie haben
oder die duh vor allem auch hass lucy
dass man mal normale sachen zum beispiel
serien machen kann
und dass man auch einfach sie da mit der
freundin alles möglich machen kann
ohne dass man nach hause kommt und
wieder auf einer baustelle
einfach mal normalität einmal einfach
aber auch mal aus flüchten aus dem
alltag lucy da haben wir eine kleine
überraschung jetzt am tag vor den feste
für dich ich schenk dir einen tag im
europapark
mit übernachtung
endlich mal raus endlich mal spaß haben
mit deinen eltern gemeinsam im
europa-park achterbahnfahrten popcorn
essen dort mal ausschlafen garantiert
mit heizung das ist eine kleine
weihnachtsfreude für euch
da wir damit eine freude machen dass sie
ja ja wir
sehen da gibt's nicht mehr viel zu sagen
ich hoffe vor weihnachten jetzt einen
tag vor dem feste ist das ein kleiner
ausblick eine kleine flucht nach all den
strapazen die sie als familie
durchmachen mussten frowein
haft nun vielen dank sehr sehr gerne
frohe weihnachten ein schönes fest ganz
viel spaß wie sie sagt gar nichts mehr
ganz viel spaß sie im europa-park lassen
es krachen dort vergessen sie die
letzten monate und genießen sie dort
spaß und ablenkung